ساشرح للقاده هنا اتفاق توفير الذخيره
لاوكرانيا لقد تم مناقشته خلال اخر اجتماع
للمجلس الاوروبي وقدمت استونيا اقتراحا
وتم تكليف بتنفيذ هذا المشروع
خلال هذه القمه ساعرض هذا المقترح على
الزعماء لامداد اوكرانيا بالذخيره وهذا
يشمل مليون طلقه على مدى 12 شهرا بتكلفه
ملياريار يورو
الاتحاد الاوروبي متحد وتعمل كل الدول مع
بعضها البعض وبشكل متضامن وهذا الشيء لم
يفكر به بوتين ابدا دعمه اوكرانيا يتم
بطريقه موحده وسيدوم طويلا
نحن مستعدون لدعم اوكرانيا طالما كان ذلك
ضروريه
ومعي الان مباشره من بروكسيل الاستاذ محمد
رجائي بركات الخبير بالعلاقات العربيه
والاوروبيه اهلا ومرحبا بك على كما تابعنا
وكما استمعنا الملف الاوكراني سيكون حاضر
بقوه ومن دون شك في هذه القمه الاوروبيه
الجديده
بالطبع الملف الاوكراني سيكون حاضر ولكن
يبدو ان هناك توافق وزراء الخارجيه
الاوروبيين الاسبوع الماضي اتفقوا على خطه
التي تحدثتم عنها في التقرير التقديم 2
مليار يورو لشراء الاسلحه
وخاصه القذائف وارسالها الى اوكرانيا
مليار يورو سيتم دفعها للدول التي ارسلت
حتى الان قذائف وذلك كي تتمكن من تجديد
مخزونها من القذائف واما الميلان الاخر
سيتم تصنيع قذائف حتى
سيستغرق ذلك ربما حتى عشره اشهر او 12
شهرا
بعض المراقبين المشكله بالنسبه لاوكرانيا
انه لا توجد لديها ذخائر كافيه تستخدم حتى
الان مدافع او قذائف
155 ملي متر
وكان في العهد السوفيتي لديها ايضا مدافع
مليمتر وبالتالي يجب تجديد هذه الدقائق
وكيف تتناسب مع المدافع التي تم ارسالها
المدافع الاطلسيه التي تم ارسالها مؤخرا
الى اوكرانيا
وايضا ربما سيتم بحث موضوع التطور الوضع
عن الناحيه العسكريه قيام بعض الدول وخاصه
بريطانيا بارسال قذائف وتحتوي على
اليورانيوم المنظم وهذا طبعا
ما ازعج روسيا وتقوم الان
بصدرت تعليقات وتصريحات من قبل مسؤولين
الروس وخاصه من الرئيس بوتين
اشارت الى انه سيتم اتخاذ الاجراءات من
قبل روسيا بهذا الخصوص معروف ان هذه
القذائف كان قد تم استخدامها خلال الحرب
في العراق وطبعا النتائجها على البيئه
وعلى المواطنين سيئه جدا
وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك العديد من
الخلافات بين الدول الاضاف الاتحاد
الاوروبي محمد رجائي بركات برز خلاف بين
وفرنسا وبرلين الاسبوع الماضي حول مكانه
الطاقه النوويه في مقترح للمفاوضيه
الاوروبيه بشان السياسات الصناعيه يعني
الى اي حد يمكن القول بان هذا الخلاف
سيلقي بظلاله على هذه القمه هذا ما كنت
تريد ان اتطرق اليه هناك خلافات فيما
يتعلق بالطاقه فرنسا تركز على استخدام
الطاقه النوويه نذكر بان الرئيس
الفرنسي مكرون كان قد تحدث عن بناء
مفاعلات نوويه صغيره يتم استخدامها
وحاولت فرنسا وا ان تحصل على اعتبار
الطاقه النوويه كطاقه متجدده ولكن يبدو ان
الخلافات مع المانيا ستمنعها من الاستفاده
من الميزات اي الحصول على تمويل اوروبي
ضمن خطه القضاء على البعثات غير ثانيه
اكسيد الكربون من الان وحتى عام
2050 ميلاديه بحيث تصبح صفر بالمئه ولكن
سيتم غدا الاجتماع يبدو ان سيكون هناك
اجتماع يوم غد بين الرئيس الفرنسي
والمستشار الالماني لبحث هذا الموضوع
والمانيا تريد لا تريد ان يتم الاستغناء
بشكل تام عن
المحروقات البنزين الى اخره خاصه في صناعه
السيارات وذلك بسبب صعوبه تنفيذ هذا
المخطط كما يقول بعض الخبراء استاذ محمد
رشا بركاته الخبير بالعلاقات العربيه
الاوروبيه اشكرك على كل هذه التوضيحات كنت
معنا مباشره من بروكسيلا